hello grammarians today we're going to
talk about a class of auxiliary or
helper verbs called the modal verbs
these are verbs that have special
properties and help other verbs but what
is modality
my fellow grammarian i am so glad you
asked modality is when we use these
verbs to express conditions on stuff so
we can use these verbs to determine if
something is likely to happen or certain
to have happened
whether or not something is possible or
whether or not we have the ability to do
something
whether or not we have the permission to
do something and whether or not we have
the obligation or requirement or need to
do something
you already know all of these verbs i
promise you you just didn't know this
name for them let's meet the modals
roll call here we go
may
might
must
can
could
shall
should
will
would
those are the modals
so here's what modal verbs can do thing
number one
they agree with everything so you can
take any one of these modals and you can
use any subject in the world and it's
not going to change right you take a
word like talk for instance and you'd
say i talk diane
talks
right you add the s but any subject in
any sentence is going to take the modal
verb the same way let me show you
i can do it you can do it she can do it
they can do it we can do it it's all the
same
they agree with everything
something else that modals do is
actually something that they don't do
they don't have a two form this is what
we call the infinitive so there's no
such thing as
to may or to could that just doesn't
exist
so modals don't have infinitives
you can't say i want to should
it doesn't that is an illegal operation
in english it is ungrammatical it
doesn't matter what version of english
you speak across all varieties of
english you cannot too should
and finally a thing that modal verbs can
do is indicate modality which like we
said establishes conditions so let's
take a look at some examples
so the word must
right
we can use the word must in a couple of
different ways
so if you imagine
a detective
looking up from some tracks some muddy
boot prints on the floor
with her magnifying glass she looks up
and she says
he must have gone that way
that detective is saying is using must
to express like a likelihood a high
likelihood this must have happened but
if you're at an amusement park and the
roller coaster you want to ride has a
height requirement the sign probably
says you must be this tall to ride the
doom coaster this is like a necessary
condition
by a similar token if you enter
someone's house and they demand that you
take off your shoes they would say you
must remove your shoes
similarly with may we can use may to
express a possibility like saying it may
rain that's something that could
possibly happen or to give someone
permission like you may enter
you can use a word like can to express
ability
you could say i can eat 10 pounds of
broccoli and that's expressing your
ability to do a thing
we also use modal verbs like this to
talk about conditions or stuff that
isn't going to happen or maybe could
happen uh and so
for example in this sentence we would
say i would make the bed but i'm tired
because the possibility exists however
remote that the bed would be made by me
but i don't feel like it
so i'm using wood to offer an excuse i'm
saying this could possibly happen this
would happen except for this one other
problem which is that i'm sleepy
you can also use modal verbs to give
advice to someone as in you shouldn't do
that
and something that is special to will
and to a lesser extent shall is that
they can form the future
shall used to be a lot more popular and
it still is in british english but less
so in standard american so you would say
he will win the competition or he shall
win the competition and use of this
modal verb will or shall indicates that
that thing that you're talking about is
happening in the future
these verbs are very powerful you should
learn how to use them and in fact if you
can complete the exercises then you will
master these tricky verbs
you can learn anything
dave it out